I like making Decks that make people
question their preconceptions about deck
building and about the EDH format as a
whole and one of my favorite examples of
this is my gissa deck it is a battle
cruiser deck that uses its command Zone
to give it a consistent highquality
early creature thereby allowing the
cards in the 99 to be a pile of greedy
high-cost nonsense just look at that
beautiful Monster of a curve this sort
of massive nonsense tribal deck is
really fun for when I don't want to play
a deck that is particularly challenging
and would prefer to just indulge my
battle cruiser desires but unfortunately
there's a problem this deck plays a
shitload of removal to disrupt opposing
game plans and this works out quite well
for the deck's General game plan ramping
to a double digit land count as fast as
possible and then turning on the Boss
music but this game plan can be a bit
contentious at times not so much that I
never play it but enough so that it
can't be my default midow fun deck for
when I don't want to think too hard
people get annoyed if I spend too much
time as the final boss all this to say
for the past 6 months I've been vaguely
looking around for a battle cruiser deck
that might be able to scratch similar
itches while being a bit less brutal to
play against a little while back
somebody mentioned to me the idea of
running R air to keld as a commander and
this got my nogin jogin you know what
sucks to draw in the late game lowcost
ramp spells any ramp deck worth its salt
needs to coordinate the ratio of ramp to
other stuff and also the ratio of
lowcost ramp to high cost ramp running a
lot of lowcost ramp leads to beautiful
curve outs and buttery smooth early to
mid games but it also leads to running
out of cards faster and worsens the
quality of later game top decks I built
a goreclaw deck a while back that ran 16
lowcost ramp spells with the goal to
land goreclaw ont turn two or three and
then vomit out a massive amount of power
and toughness on turns four and five the
deck did a great job of accomplishing
exactly that task but it pretty much
either won quickly or ran out of steam
after eating a couple removal spells or
a board wipe running a lot of draw is
the best way to avoid this in a that
runs a lot of lowcost dorks but despite
my best efforts I couldn't manage to
cram the necessary amount of draw into
the deck without incurring a substantial
cost to the beefiness of the deck on the
opposite end of the ramp Spectrum
there's the option of running a lot of
high-cost ramp Instead This preserves
top Tech quality and lessens the number
of cards needed to achieve the same
degree of ramp however it will lead to
slower games and fewer keepable hands
worsening an X Mulligan phase and its
ability to get off the ground but what
if there was a way to the inverse of
what was done in the gor claw deck to
have the commander cover the lowcost
ramp and then run a massive pile of for
cost ramp this is where R comes back in
as a two drop manad dor that's available
at all times one potential rata build
could be to run a lot of four to five
cost plays but these tend to be a lot
worse than six to seven cost cards
dropping a generically high quality four
drop on turn three such as forgotten
ancient or atsushi is a lot less
impressive than dropping a kogla or an
ital Primal storm onto turn four and
creatures that are six or more Mana also
tend to stay relevant as top decks
whereas four to five Mana creatures are
by contrast often kind of disappointing
to top deck later in the game this is
not to say that we're going to be trying
to let the deck get to a point where
what's on top of its library is all
important but when you're playing a
cheap red green mid-range deck you got
to know that there will be some games
where you don't find enough of your draw
and end up relying on the heart of the
cards and in those cases you'll usually
be glad to draw a dragon layer spider
instead of an arasta so this was my
start in building Rada four cost ramp
that I can play on turn three there are
some different options here including
some really potent manad dorks that
might allow for an extra explosive turn
four to five but I made my decision of
what to put here largely with the intent
of hedging around a potential weakness
for the deck see Green Stompy decks tend
to struggle with one type of card above
all others board wipes and while manad
dorks often allow for faster
acceleration than other types of ramp
they have the downside that they
generally get eaten by board wipes
alongside the big threats that prompted
the wipe a big goal for this deck was to
be able to ramp relatively quickly into
six and seven drops but also being able
to play through hate and keep scaling
into the late game the ramp Suite I
ended up landing on focused on a classic
explosive vegetation I run all 10 of
these effects that exist as well as
blighted Woodland an untapped land that
can also serve as turn three ramp if I
activate it during combat after
attacking with Rada from there the deck
Ventures into a bunch of other cards
that perform some sort of ramp function
including extra land spells like Mina
and den filtering cards that produce
Treasures such as unexpected windfall
and a handful of other cards since I
want some sort of ramp on turn three
every single game to allow me to play a
six drop on turn four I opted for 19
total cards that offer turn three ramp
that gives a 79% chance of drawing one
in each opening hand a figure that is
high enough to leave some room for to
Mulligan for lands with my core idea of
the deck consisting of Rada and a pile
of for cost ramp I had a question on my
hands how much lowcost stuff should I
run I knew that it wouldn't be a big
amount and I eventually decided on
literally none at all and this is for
one key reason Cascade a big downside of
cascade is how luck based it is when you
play a five cost Cascade card it might
hit a four cost card but it also might
hit a one cost card however if you
simply don't run any cards that cost
less than four you're guaranteed a
pretty decent minimum level of value
from your Cascade trigger this fact
paired with my density of ramp on four
means that Cascades and discovers are
actually reasonably predictable
cascading for a four or less cost card
yields an 85% chance of finding a card
with some sort of ramp attached and
cascading for a five or less card yields
a 2/3 chance of finding specifically a
ram spell but an additional 14% chance
of finding a card that Cascades for four
which I must remind you has an 85%
chance of finding a ramp spell cascading
for a six or less cost card has a more
modest 40% chance of finding a ramp
spell but if we account for the Cascade
and Discover Cards this ends up getting
boosted up to a 55% chance what this
silly jumble of numbers means in
practice is that the deck is effectively
running a high 20s number of ramp spells
and all of them ramp for at least Le two
Mana or have other upside translation
we're in lands town baby so what does
the deck spend the resulting mana on as
I alluded to earlier a big place to
spend this Mana is on six to seven Mana
creatures as these work well both late
and as a juicy turn four play a lot of
these are exactly what you'd expect a t
Primal storm rampaging bths a decent
handful of cascade creatures but some
others are a bit further off the Beaten
Track and this is motivated by a couple
factors for one I wanted to build this
deck on a pretty tight budget both for
the sake of my wallet and to force me
into some more creative directions so
nothing over
$4 secondly The Deck ramps very hard and
has a very high curve and there are
cards that work well with this one such
card is screamer killer a card from the
Warhammer 40K set that's shockingly
close to being a terror of the peaks in
my deck but at a tiny fraction of the
price of that fancy dragon another
favorite of mine is emergent woodworm a
card that's so underplayed and causes
such a large swing and board the turn it
enters that I frequently have opponents
do a double take and ask wait that card
does what I also run tyrants familiar
and thunderfoot bth these are quite
powerful with a commander in play but
most decks can't take full advantage of
them because opponents can simply remove
their Commander before attacks which
ends up being a soft two for one however
since my commander is a manad dor that I
don't really care about past turn four
four or five my opponents are far less
eager to remove her and she's pretty
cheap to replay to get the lieutenant
ability back online if they do remove
her a big theme among the rest of the r
deck's high-cost creatures is something
that it shares with my glissa deck a
large portion of the deck's creatures
have some sort of removal attached this
is great as it allows the deck to pack a
lot of ways to deal with opposing
threats while also allowing the deck to
put on pressure by having a large
density of big creatures that it starts
playing on turn four the deck also packs
some amount of draw but far less than
you'd expect there are seven engines and
two one-time draw spells and while
playing the first dozen or so games with
the deck I've kept expecting to need to
add more draw but it just hasn't been
necessary the deck does a perfectly fine
job maintaining resources in its hand
this once again goes back to the Mana
curve even though the deck gets massive
land counts since roughly a third of the
deck is creatures that cause five or
more Mana it often stocks up a handful
of large threats earlier in the game
giving it plenty of time time to find a
draw engine as it builds up its land
count this is supplemented by the
Cascade explosive vegetation plan which
thins the deck of lands and to a lesser
extent ramp spells helping it to draw
into more big threats later I'm broadly
not too impressed by the effective deck
thinning in Commander as a couple fewer
lands won't have a wildly meaningful
impact on a deck that is looking to win
by turn eight or nine scale this up
though and pulling eight or more lands
out of a deck that is looking to grind
way into the lake game does start to
become decidedly more impactful the
Confluence of the Rat deck's intense
density of ramp vast number of high-cost
threats and adequate quantity of draw
ends up being a deck that stockpiles all
game resources at the same time it
develops board while ramping hard and
maintaining plenty of resources in hand
and this fact leads to the deck's
biggest strength its
flexibility against faster decks it can
dig in its heels and focus on staying
alive until it has the resources to
stabilize knowing it'll easily outscale
the other decks later in the game
whereas against Decks that go bigger
than it in the late game the deck can
advance a bunch of large creatures and
turn them sideways to get that deck down
to a manageable life total before it
gets too scary the deck also plays
through most hate just fine it doesn't
run significant numbers of artifacts
enchantments graveyard synergies or
pivotal singular creatures board wipes
are basically the only commonly played
hate in EDH that causes problems for a
turbo ramping big creature your deck and
the deck plays decently well through
these two advancing a few threats is all
that's needed to have a board WIP worthy
board State and this generally leaves
plenty of beefy stuff in hand and far
more lands than opponents for purposes
of playing that stuff back out the de
Cascade creatures are also a thing that
feels perfectly fine to play into a
board wipe since they usually find some
sort of ramp that can help the deck
bounce back more quickly after the wipe
before I spend too much time indulgently
hyping up my deck I should talk about
the downsides of the deck
for one it lacks basically any instant
speed interaction if I'm being generous
it has a grand total of four instant
speed removal cards and one instant
speed protection card this is mostly a
product of the deck being a Cascade deck
that runs no cards below four Mana the
desirable options for instant speed
interaction are pretty slim in addition
the deck is extremely consistent in
early turns an attribute that comes with
both positives and negatives the
positive is that as long as it Mull
properly the deck basically never has do
nothing games the downside is twofold
for one it can be a little boring since
the deck has basically no meaningful
decisions between the Mulligan phase and
turn four the other issue is that it's
predictable since opponents who have
played against the deck know its rough
curve out of the first four turns the
fact that the deck is locked into this
curve out is another reason why I opted
for the $50 budget it literally cannot
increase the speed of its curve outs so
any deck that's doing something
substantially more relevant on turn four
than playing a six or seven drop beater
is too far above the deck's power level
to be worth trying to match the deck
also requires a very aggressive Mulligan
policy to make sure it is able to get
off the ground okay though at least it
usually does fine starting with five or
six cards all of these downsides are
pretty fundamentally tied to the deck's
Core Construction having a deck with no
cards costing less than four Mana still
curve out at a decent speed requires
making some concessions here and there
at the end of the day the process of
building this deck was the process of
chasing a Vibe it's the vibe I was
chasing with my first commander deck
it's the vibe I was chasing when I made
gissa Cruiser and it's a vibe that I'll
hopefully call it quits with chasing now
that I have this R deck this Vibe of
having all the resources of being the
big bat at the table of playing
mid-range to the bleeding edge of what
that term can possibly mean I just find
it super fun and I think it makes for a
cool table dynamic as long as the deck
question has enough interaction to me
building a deck that satisfies a
particular feeling is one of the best
parts of casual Commander especially if
the resulting deck ends up being strange
and unique the challenge of making a
deck that is conceptually cool enjoyable
to play and good for table Dynamics is a
fun one to navigate and when it works
out the results can be really
great that's all for this video thanks
for watching I'll be posting an end note
to my patreon tomorrow where I discuss
some of the weirder choices in the deck
that didn't make it into the video
that's right I didn't even talk about
the caves package I'm also currently
taking submissions for a bonus video
later this month where I give my
thoughts on three Patron decks so if you
want the chance of having your deck
reviewed by me you can sign up for my
patreon and submit your deck within the
next week